good morning we start today with some
breaking news three children are in a
life-threatening condition after a knife
attack in a playground in southeast
France
it happened in the Alpine town of anisee
police say four children were injured in
total an adult has also suffered
life-threatening injuries according to a
police spokesman in the area in the last
few moments the French President
Emmanuel Macon has also tweeted about
the attack he wrote attack of absolute
cowardice this morning in a park in
anisee children and an adult are between
life and death the nation is in shock
our thoughts are with them as well as
their families and the Emergency
Services who have been mobilized well
France's interior Minister has confirmed
the attacker has been detained in a
tweet he wrote several people including
children were injured by an individual
armed with a knife in a square in anisee
the individual was arrested thanks to
the very rapid intervention of the
police
well our International correspondent
John Sparks joins us now from The
Newsroom
um John is there any more information
than what I've just read out as to what
has happened
ice Matt that this is a developing story
it's also a very disturbing story as
well very limited details at the moment
but what we know is that a man armed
with a knife attacked a group of
children and adults as well in a park in
anisee annasie is a beautiful medieval
town in the French Alps it would be very
busy at this time of year a lot of
tourists and residents as well out on
the streets what we understand is that
two of those children have are now in a
life-threatening condition and those
children there are reports that those
children are both three years old also
one adult as well in a life-threatening
condition so they have suffered very
serious injuries indeed the others
minor injuries we understand although
this is early days we are still getting
details through as you said the French
he said that a individual has been
arrested thanks to the rapid
intervention of the police and we have
just received a report
uh saying that the attacker the knife
attacker is a Syrian National with legal
Refugee status
in France uh with yes with legal Refugee
status in France so these details coming
through right now
and I see would again be very busy at
this time of year it is a very popular
tourist town medieval tight squares sort
of place that people love to go at this
time of year in the summer so it will be
really really very very disturbing for
people there we've heard from macro as
well the French President very upset I
can tell you that they broke off a
debate in the National Assembly in Paris
and the lawmakers there held a one
minute period of Silence so
developing a situation also very
disturbing story as well particularly
for people in France
yes indeed we will of course be bringing
you any police statement or indeed a
statement from president Marco as and
when it happens for now John thank you